do we have rich on yet for the uh
olympic episode he has been on hold for
like five minutes
with god oh that's susie eisenhower
that's right charles
charles knows where his bread is
buttered hi there rich how are you
hey hon how are you hi honey how are you
we're good rich what golf course on you
are you on right now i am not at all as
a matter of fact there's a tornado alert
for uh
tornado alert for connecticut yeah i
might be seeing auntie
m and toto flying by very shortly
i don't think they have any shelters in
connecticut for tornadoes
i'm on the fourth floor of this hotel so
but uh i just checked there's a nice
spot underneath the bed wow oh great you
haven't been through enough this month
today so i'm sorry you haven't been
through enough this month covid and then
a tornado yeah
kobed got through that but the
connecticut tornado is coming
that's what i'm told so we're hunkered
down here in the uh in the nutmeg state
but uh that's what's going on here house
what's good
that's what's going on here let's see
what's going on in your neck of the
woods
well rich we had a wonderful uh
breakdown on the 405 today
no we're not going to do the the news
and weather on the ones here right for
for southern california jack knife big
rig i did throw chris under the bus
rich i did throw your how was your uh
memory lane with joe madden
please well it was great it was amazing
i was trying to tell you
it was great until i threw chris under
the bus and told me yeah you'd
appreciate that richard was great
just launched under that just basically
chris is trying to pull himself
out from underneath the semi outside of
the studio because i said to joe
chris doesn't believe that he's mvp
because your team isn't winning right he
being ohtani
i think rich as you know there's a
difference between valuable and
outstanding it's just whatever your
definition
is this is not you know what this is i i
am going to
um you see you did not throw him under
the bus
you gave an accurate portrayal of the
take
that brockman has had on this subject
consistently i might add thank you
but now it is time no but now it is time
to pay the reaper
to have this said to the face or the
eardrum of the person
who would have a big problem with that
take what did joe madden have to say
about it well he did he did not
directly call me an a-hole which was
which was nice but he just
explained you know what he sees every
single day and why he thinks
you know shohei is the clear runaway
winner
going to be the winner of the award
which i agree with i just think
you know i want the angels to play
meaningful games i want them to be in
the postseason
so we can see what this kid can do with
the bright lights you don't want to see
that
come on don't don't i do as a fan of
baseball
yeah okay this is you know what this
reminds me of this is
similar to uh when method man was in
studio and i forced you to tell him the
take that i'm not from staten i'm not a
new yorker because i'm from staten
island
very similar that's the same thing well
i mean joe madden a little less
frightening than method man
and that was a person he was 20 feet
away from me right
there these were fighting words for
madden if he was physically in studio
possibly possible yeah you could hear
him take a deep breath as he was
answering rich
like and you know me i was sitting here
loving every second
i mean i will say and and you know to
give kudos to myself i didn't
directly say look joey shouldn't win
because you guys suck joe like i didn't
say that i you know i carefully danced
around it
all right well don't hurt yourself
patting yourself on the bathroom did a
good job
i've had a big week as an insider you've
had a really good week chris
rich he's been excellent this week i
didn't say that on the radio wait i just
did
he's been pretty good this week but rich
if you want to listen to that joe madden
interview or you want to watch it
you just go to peacock it's streaming
you can find it
there on peacock or on youtube or follow
the rich eisen show on twitter and i'm
sure it'll be out there just want to let
you know how to watch your own show
you're such a team player rich more
importantly i don't know if you saw the
news you've probably been getting tagged
in it a lot in the last 20 minutes
the deal is done zach wilson and the
jets have agreed to terms
he's gonna get his signing bonus within
15 days
the jets get all their offset whatever
that means
and he is in camp and getting reps well
i'm just glad the jets
held the line um in a way
that they can feel comfortable with
for them to at least point to
when they draft another quarterback in
the first round three years from now
so they've got those bases covered i'm
so glad they got that one done
i mean come on yeah and he'll get free
q-tips for life it's going to be great
so is that what it was they didn't want
to pay him his money
this deferred money like they've i i
don't understand did they not have
enough in their account in july
and they're they're gonna have a chat
like woody johnson's check is gonna
clear in august
i don't know but uh but i'm glad that
he's in
he'll get the reps as you know he's got
a
he's a young he's very young we're going
to find out very shortly if the jets
have the
the next namuth broadway zach zach smith
avenue
goldman zachs whatever you want to call
it oh my god
or of skip learn his mom
and his mother uh soon enough meanwhile
meanwhile mack jones is
first on the field in new england uh oh
my god
johnny smith says he's got swagger like
oh man i'm so hype already
and you were so pissed i was so mad
oh my gosh please we need to get that
drop for
for this year every single time that you
talk about how great matt jones is
if he gets out there but this is great
isn't it like it's great
it's great camp is back and training
camp started
and aaron rodgers is in and
randall cobb made brockman seem like
he's a shepherd
ian rapper portal rolled into one and
um you know the drama is already
ratcheting up i i love it
yeah we got a sense from andrew brandt
that there was going to be some
interesting drama laying out ahead of us
for the year with aaron rodgers
well i mean you're already seeing i mean
gurdacoon said today
you know that they made the deal rotten
randall cobb
because aaron wanted it right and and
that
and and everything that he laid out as
you know where we're gonna come up with
a plan to factor
aaron's thoughts into our process it's
like
why the hell do you need your
quarterback to essentially
you know hold his breath in the corner
you know or or act like the sheriff in
uh blazing saddles putting his own gun
to his head to make the townspeople
think he's gonna pull the trigger
you know what why did you need to have
something like that happen in order to
do
like what you should do with your goat
quarterback
as he's entering a 17th year which by
the way
neither farv nor bart starr was ever did
it's just it's just shocking that
they're like yeah you know where
aaron wanted this thing and and it's
just like
typical rogers and the fact that you
know he kind of rescued randall cobb
from
houston and bringing him in where he can
mentor the guy who is supposedly the
next randall cobb
and also give rogers a pelt on the wall
that makes them feel better about coming
to work
and um it i it's
it's kind of mind-boggling but i i think
rogers is going to get what he wants
this year which is all right aaron your
show
all right aaron you know mason crosby we
won't send him out on fourth and goal
anymore
got it like this is it like this is your
last rodeo potentially or
the beginning of the final years that
you have here because it's all
been figured out although yesterday's
press conference made it seem like it
was not
how amazing was that press conference
yesterday all 32 minutes just
unbelievable
well you know i mean the statement that
i think that might
you know resonate a little bit um
it was him saying that green bay wasn't
a vacation
destination and that people are coming
to green bay to play with him yeah
and be there with him and win with him
and you know none of what he said was
was
you know false but i think there's a lot
of prideful cheeseheads
who for 30 years are used to
people you know green bay having
generationally talented quarterbacks
because they're green bay
you know and there may be a lot of
people saying you know so you don't like
living here i thought you know you loved
living here and you loved the community
and loved the fans and you kind of
called it a not a vacation destination
you know and that might rankle some
people but again tom eats ball
he's throwing it he's playing it at mvp
caliber people are going to love him
you know once again and um every game is
going to be
high drama thoroughly high drama
little mini series mini seasons in
in in one week they're the team to watch
all year long
uh it's gonna be amazing yeah no one's
gonna care when he lights up the bears
for
404 touchdowns well except the bears
you know they might care andy dalton
just them
also by the way can you think of the
package that the better business bureau
will send out like come to green bay
come take your vacation and watch aaron
rodgers
actually maybe you might say it's a new
campaign
that's right shotgun beers with
bhaktiari that's some of the
you know uh state of champions you know
the bucks and we'll see if the packers
do it and
you know uh uh but again it's just like
i said yesterday and and
throughout the the weeks leading up to
the season and
we'll be talking about it every week
during the season
it really is about what brady did and
what brady's been able to accomplish and
what every other quarterback wants and
what every other team thinks they can
they can do by swapping out a new
quarterback and
obviously not not all of it's going to
work out very
very few of it's going to work out but
um
like i said every game is just going to
be totally lit i was just thinking
yesterday we're talking
here um in connecticut because you know
i'm at the nbc
headquarters and they're all just like
you know bucks and cowboys and it's just
you sit there and you think about it
and it's just so amazing it's gonna be
so lit you know and now you know
tj is is dak hurt like what's going on
with him right now we're gonna get
another reach my sources
worked out i think they did cut ben
danucci right
so i don't know if he's gonna be there
my sources tell me doc's shoulder is
just sore it's just precautionary rich
we
just you know we don't want to put too
much stress everyone's got sources now
yeah you know i had i had to talk with
someone in oxnard
last yesterday afternoon and they told
me now i didn't go to twitter
and break the story i should have but i
i didn't even think about it but
he'll be fine today or is mike there
today or he's not there
sorry rich eisen no he's not not
oh that's a great drop
what does that drop read does it read
what's the name of that
rich eyes and child john's name what
does it say it says ciao at the end
yeah doesn't say junk says ciao
his filing system is a total complete
hot mess there's a lot of
buttons over here yeah all right very
good oh come on guys you know how i feel
about attacking del tufo on the air
there's no bullying this is happy
thursday sorry rich it's a happy
thursday
we're calling this happy thursday it's
been a heavy week rich
and we are just we're here to celebrate
women's gold
men's swimming gold what is your
tokyo gold moment or sport of the day
well the uh richard rich eisen
shuttlecock minute today
uh focused on the sport of uh
two uh two person two men two women
dinghy
this is what it's called what this is
essentially what yeah it's a boat a boat
and two people in the boat
um and i may or may not have printed out
the lyrics to sailing by christopher
crawford
oh god for those highlights i part i
apologize you will be humming it the
rest of the day now
you know it yep um and uh i may or may
not have talked about how the canvas can
do miracles
um you know plus you wait and see you
have to wait
and see that's correct um you didn't do
it in a falsetto or something weird did
you
no sue you you you got me off the hall
falsetto
um with me doing my hockey call if he
shoots he scores
that was the most annoying call of all
time
you should do that all remember that on
sportscenter chris he's going i was like
you got to stop that
it's amazing we have children
[Laughter]
it's a shocker it's a shocker richie
our children exist richard caller
yesterday asked if uh
susie had lost a bet when she married
you i thought that was so really good
it was aggressive and here's the deal
which
she didn't confirm or did not she just
kind of like when that
well my sources say tj we all got horses
oh my gosh well she said that you gave
her an ultimatum
whoa oh did you tell that story
not really yeah she just like said that
and then was like all right let's go to
break we're like hold on
then we came back they're like you're
going to tell the rest of the story i
said absolutely not it's the rich
eisenhower everybody
there you go all right so tokyo gold so
we have
is there really a sport called dinghy
yeah yeah i mean it's like sailing and
and it's pretty amazing um
the uh we had our first uh baseball
highlight
today on our second one um it was
um uh south korea against israel
um and um uh i
said it was the uh south korea against
the only team
uh in the field who's starting on is one
short of a minion
which is uh hebrew humor guy all the
rest of you there wouldn't know uh you
can't
start you can't start a religious
ceremony in judaism without
ten men being there ten bar mitzvahed
men being there yeah feller's the only
one laughing at the moment
i've got my hand in my head and feathers
laughing
dude the highlight was cut tight because
my
my my plan was to say you know for uh
when it went to extras that the israelis
were excited to have
uh uh bigger portions uh of baseball
um so there's just so many lines that
i'm i'm
i'd like to say and i don't say i don't
get a chance to say but
that's what tokyo gold is all about you
know oh and by the way you know caleb
dressel was terrific and seeing his
family
and just moving moments like that
and all these sports archery returns to
the show tomorrow which makes me very
excited
um and uh that's day six day six
already at the olympics in the books
you're missing chris brockman is
i'm just about to throw up i'm loving
these days like i just know you're so
proud of yourself for all these one
like when he said cut tight i thought he
was going somewhere else exactly me too
you kidding me this is the proudest uh
that i'm very proud of
i'm very proud of that again i might
uncork that line that i put the jew in
judo
i've got that in my back pocket too but
uh we haven't brought that i haven't
brought that out just yet
that's in my quiver well done hey
everybody you can download peacock you
can stream
every single minute of this goal this is
tokyo gold
tokyo gold you think that you think that
the gold is the metals
oh no stand out in tokyo gold but no no
no one liners like that that's the gold
that's the gold gold yes where is karis
need when we need her
this is humor that only the two of you
can appreciate
good times oh god all right rich hey
stay safe
stay safe avoid the
be worried i've been tornado out the
window this entire time yeah dunking
cover if need be
but make sure you record if you see any
cars flying and stuff i will do that
yeah put that on tick tock rich and then
you know that'll go by
it'll be like tom pelissaro with the
video of aaron walking in
we'll run it and we won't give you
credit
that's the way we roll thank you goodbye
rich
all right after the show hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here